so what exactly is a hangover well a lot  of people think that a hangover is just  dehydration but actually a hangover is a  collection of a whole bunch of metabolic  problems your body is trying to in  essence digest and break down a toxic  ethanol is the main ingredient in  alcohol that gives us the buzz and  really is the main reason that we drink  it but there are a lot of other things  in alcohol some of them break down into  components like formaldehyde which is  what we use to involve corpses some of  them become acetone which you might know  as nail polish remover all of these  other chemicals can lead to irritation  of the nervous system can lead to the  feeling of being toxic and it takes a  long time for our kidneys to clear these  other products if you look at all of  those and treat them all individually  then you're going to get rid of your  hangover a little bit faster I'm dr.  Keller we're them and that's a hangover  tip